[Musik]
stand stunden deutsche parlamentsarbeit
mit gernot hassknecht etwas
ungeheuerliches ist geschehen nach
gerade mal zwölf jahren im amt muss
angela merkel
die amtierende herrscherin deutschland
und der angeschlossenen europäischen
länder erstmals den abgeordneten des
bundestags regelrecht fragen beantworten
ihre politik erklären in england gibt es
das schon seit 1961 und zwar jede woche
alter geht es da zur sache hier so wird
dann gefragt
[Applaus]
peter
juli
ich möchte diese frau heiraten so hart
so geht demokratie der wettstreit um die
besten ideen und jetzt gucken wir mal
wie das am mittwoch im bundestag war
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin frau
bundeskanzlerin frau bundeskanzlerin
kannst frau bundeskanzlerin meine frage
meine konkrete frage und der frage nicht
nur ich mich warum wandern warum ja oder
nein
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass
ich ihnen das heute noch nicht sagen
kann
[Applaus]
auch schön nur halt auf valium jede
frage nur eine minute rückfragen
verboten alles ist an der abgeperlt wie
an seiner alten tesla keinen bock mehr
ich gehe jetzt in den sommerurlaub zwölf
wochen und warum weil ich kann
irgendwo müssen die gebühren ja hin aber
bevor es losgeht hab ich noch eine to do
liste für die marke derzeit mit erstes
regel dass über den sommer mit europa
damit uns der laden hier nicht
auseinanderfliegt unterschreibt einfach
alles was der makro die hinlegt du hast
ja eh keine eigenen ideen
zweitens wenn du trend weh tun willst
nimm endlich steuern von amazon und
google
und drittens schmeißt den unverschämten
neuen us-botschaft daraus diesen
kriminellen einfach nach hause schicken
und zwar jetzt wird böse mit
was du falsch mein flieger geht
mit bunten bildschirm zu erhalten